[Music]
hello mama do it on a stunning episode
of what's in the box man I'm shaggy I'm
scooping and guess what before we get
anything going on we need to pull out a
knife that's just like what every child
always says before we get have fun let's
get the knives we got that what we're
gonna do is open this box surgically
dive in see what's inside just like kids
do with their small pets that's what I
like my name is Oliver Queen
this is that TV show where the boy never
has a shirt on I came back with a
mission to bring justice to our city
okay John Diggle Arsenal arrow and
Felicity Smoak oh my gosh
hold on there's more arrow Starling city
badge in Signet so today I want to wear
it I thought it was perfume for a second
I was like not more superhero for a few
spare no I was sprayed on New York oh
this fool loves the shirtless boy show
that's what I call it he calls it arrow
he Tunes in every episode he's like you
gotta watch it he goes up to save it
bored shoot strong moves the men and
women I've targeted her dangerous
corrupt you're such a big fan of this
guy don't downplay you that's more in
the fireman
all right here we go
oh dude who doesn't want the Starling
metro I'll be honest with you I would
because this I know it is Star City not
Starling city just like I know him as
Green Arrow not as arrow but he's called
Green Arrow now they've taken over all
the networks on the show he tells
everyone now he's gonna be the new
protector of the city I am
the green arrow and he's fighting back
sweet man so there's a badge so you
could pretend you're who who carries
this this guy
uh no Diggle doesn't do it this is for
detective Lance hey kids did you ever
want to be black Canary's dad here's a
badge I don't want you hanging out with
Oliver Queen he is the reason Sara got
killed you know what not for nothing but
that's pretty good thanks that's not bad
like and you're well-known enough you
should be on one of these shows why not
you was the white Diggle or something
like that I could have been at least
Felicity Smoak and [ __ ] like if that's
the case not really but I've seen an
episode because I love the flash show
I'll step on your neck if you get
between me and my flash programmes flash
is my story this seems to be your story
I'm always like hey you want to do
something like ooh shoot oh boy but
there's now but they're intertwined like
there's so many so I've seen an episode
two exes and you know it's not like it's
fine it's just not flash this part of
the show this looks so strange to me
these two do is this student is
metrosexual life mate we're standing
next to green and the rebbe or stand
next to each other and they you know
they were like we got like they were
holding an arrow on people with guns
I've been reading this mall life I wrote
green air at one point but oh I watching
the show I was a psych this is corny
these kids give you their asses shot but
they didn't house amazing thing they're
so good
let's look at the green arrow right now
I'm pero as they call them in this day
look at it he's all sinned you look at
the crotch out here take him out just
take him out as well take all these uh
take the other arrow Arsenal is this
meant to be Roy Harper yes so you know
they'll awesome think about Roy Harper
in the comics and he came like a junkie
man there's a very striking cover of
speedy like tying off dude really like
darkness it's a landmark issue and the
green arrow beat his ass so he's like
gets over a lot of leather on this show
admit it dude there is what are you
talking about wearing leather the boys
are all taking their shirts to look at
this the little arrows go in the back
are they all separate yeah most of them
there's a couple signals can you show me
tell you something man DC collectibles
ah they could probably replace my wife
with a Stepford version and I wouldn't
notice it because the the craftsmanship
is amazing
alright the only way I'd noticed as if
the figure was nice to man that I'd be
like you know my wife Deathstroke
where's that figure there's shirtless
boy figure and no dude I would not play
with Diggle he has no costume or
anything on it neither does she would
you play with felicity smoak no because
there'd be rear Cazalas she's really
good on a computer she's like a tech
hacker look above you there should be
insulated by being pumping the arena
she received should Oliver Queen so all
you do is be like I put a pin in that
real quick Matt what what does she do
with Oliver Queen
she seems for them you made a whole
[ __ ] career Ben look you [ __ ] man
a booty weirdo [ __ ] and you're like
she sleeps with them so what do you have
planned for the rest of the day well in
like this is the one place in your life
you're gonna be respectful because it's
aro what yeah on the show Holly don't
[ __ ] her he makes love to yes could you
[ __ ] someone in this this is for making
love looks like
do this looks like ice cream eating this
through the bath house like wonder what
kind of a seat I'm getting into why do
you think that he has interchangeable
hands but aro does not how does she have
interchangeable hands the hand she comes
with they're both clenched fists and the
knees I would imagine our typing hands
this is a pointer finger that's always
just like what did you say like you
destroy the city digging or you let the
city down fail this city that's a you
have failed this city
you have failed this city
[Music]
black face gone and once again kids I
mean I know I've said it before and I
hate to sound like a broken record but
heavens it takes too long to take
Felicity Smoak out of the package
look this is disappointing me can you
please get that out of there thank god
I've always had you as a friend open the
toys even a Christmas I had to build
something for his I didn't have to build
I said have built it it was a gift for
his kid when I invited him to my house
and had him building it then I wrapped
he gave it to his kids I'm gonna take a
moment here to like look at this is the
modern-day arrows not Green Arrow look
he's got side arrows does he just whip
them out of oh yeah
sasai-sensei says hi says bison you're
sleeping darts heal stress hacking
boxing love error he did use that one
get out of here wasn't a boxing guevara
but he put the boxing block on to the
air that sombitch toe get shot in the
face with her oh yeah I was crying her
make me watch the show all right this is
what green arrow looks like today but
I'm gonna pull classic green arrow oh
god see we got let's see the difference
yes kids this was once the only green
arrow
you could get look at that beard he's
got the you know the Van Dyke that's not
a lot of people go always goatee goatee
goes all the way around here Van Dyke's
just mustache and then chin hair and
stuff nothing on the cheeks
um look at him he's got the big-ass guns
those are the gun show he is cuz you
know how hard it is pull back to ever
try an arrow oh no oh yeah yeah hard
right I can never get past oh my god
it's like doing a pull-up in if I can do
you ever see me try to pull up yeah when
you pawn up over on the side of my bed
trying to get my closet hey what are you
sleeping on the ceiling my bed but
you're laying down you slide in good up
and you sneak up on my bed Jordan sleep
behind your wife's back alright you got
me there the subterfuge that's why I
would be low this is what a green arrow
looked like back in the day and look his
arrows are cemented in you can't pull
him out and stuff but he does have this
awesome like arm things look I don't
know what you call these these gauntlets
man like it they're not practical oh
that's so it doesn't hurt his wrist when
he's shooting that big compound bow is
that what it is yeah that what this is
yeah are you [ __ ] me like oh my god
I'm reading comics ball I pose always
like well it's a flourish that's a
practical thing and it's like having a
hawker like a falconers glove yes you
learned something on this show
all right so this is what he looked like
back when we were kids this is what he
looks like now I mean the size of
doesn't matter that's my wife tells me
so sighs outside of this equation which
is the cooler better Green Arrow
I'll give it to you again well not the
toy because clearly DC Direct has gotten
like they've cracked the code like this
is a far superior toy to this but in
terms of the look and the feel of Green
Arrow like you know this guy's like you
failed the city - yeah this guy's like
you fat cats I'm gonna hit you with a
boxing glove arrow if you're asking me
which one reminds me more of the arrow
growing up reading comics and all that
stuff this is what I see as I picture
the air green arrow hmm but yes I'm a
big fan of the show and I'm a big fan of
this man here what would you be willing
to pay for that fake badge willing to
pay like 20 bucks $19.99 you might have
to pay a little bit more $10 more $29.99
you get to have that badge but that
badge probably worked me walk into a
7-eleven okay man I'll give me one of
those hot dogs on the roller so like
this is my K yo mol hey hey I overpaid
for this bra it's molded from the actual
TV show props oh that's kind of cool
oh my lord they just sold one $49.99 now
I'll pay for this sumbitch
I'll overpay telling you man who would
be more happy new to be on the show no I
don't know this guy I bet you when this
guy got the call no like you're gonna be
arrow he was a green arrow know it [ __ ]
no just arrow I bet she was happiest
[ __ ] I bet you you would be even happier
than him if they were like hey do you
want to come on the show and play you
know the dick skin or whatever the
villain of the week is and stuff like
what you'd roll it's here you'd be like
I'm gonna meet Diggle in real life I'm
gonna be dick scared I love it
how much you think you pay for a figure
looks as good as any one of these well I
would say because really about it's the
same [ __ ] price every week
all right $24.99 yes see you applied
yourself man
just like the arrow himself you lied
yourself you Simon board it up to the
nose nice
can you do an episode of arrow with just
these four figures
no what's missing a bad guy Deathstroke
the point what would have Diggle want
bad vehicle he's not much of a challenge
I don't think for either one of these
two good man with a gun not be a
challenge for a man with a bow and arrow
because he sees that [ __ ] coming five
miles away he'd better keep it to again
kkuk Ison I need to kick him but these
two you get em every month I say you
should get a role on the show you should
direct a whole episode the question is
would you buy these toys for yourself
would I buy these for myself no but I
have the flash figures i flash captain
cold I'd buy all the flash figures and I
could just recreate if every episode by
myself not every episode because is
crossover so you'd need these figures
but I'm not the target audience you are
the fan
what is the fan say I already do have
the Deadshot figure hmm and I would buy
the Deathstroke figure mmm I know ever
buying felicity smoak you ever seen I
would never buy from why can't you why
why can't you support yours is the sons
of [ __ ] like you there ain't no Ray
figure in the Monopoly game of force
awakens man she's got saran wrap around
her ponytail
that's what ladies do my cheesy choke on
that bro I can't have Oh your kid can't
choke it's a little pocket air although
he's got your look but that'd be worth
it Camero arrow who is green I wouldn't
buy these figures and let's be honest
Warren I'm buying is Felicity Smoak and
not for dirty reasons no not for dirty
reasons just because like you gotta buy
more girl figures otherwise they don't
make the girl figures then you get a
teen Batman varying it's like Batman and
snowsuit Batman in [ __ ] metal Serena
Batman an anti girl suit because there's
no [ __ ] girl care okay here's my
question she got glasses too who don't
want to buy an extra person I could see
but if I bought a girl figure i buy the
canary oh I gotta be the action fighty
one what's the matter with the smart
girl why can't you bought a smart girl
action figure you have smart girl
offense I like her character a lot
actually the mom weren't you about a
figure because I just don't see this
standing on my wants almost like a
department I do I literally see it
sitting on a lot of crap that you've got
you think this would be out of place
yeah for me unless I am gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna shame you in a buy one all
right how about this if you were stunned
she alright fair enough
well there it is man
we wanted to know what was in the box
and we found out it's a bunch of aero
stuff and this guy is beside himself
come on fire him into arrow make him
somebody that arrow kills ya that's fine
you don't care kill me
yeah kill me with your your boxing
gloves wiener arrow kick he just lost a
job sorry yeah I'm trying to get you a
job you know put my wiener I don't like
it coming we don't want that guy around
here um that's all we got time for this
week man thanks for seeing what we have
in the box big thanks to the folks of DC
director for making such fine products
and stuff that are in the box
what do you want to see us pull out of
the box man dignity
good luck write in and tell us what you
would like to see us open ups will open
anything our hearts our wallets and
stuff like that just write to the screen
junkies a Twitter and Facebook and
probably there's an address down here
that you could write to as well let them
know what you want to see us open up
here right here on what's in the box but
until next week man I'm Kevin Smith he's
him you know what was in the box this
week what's in the bar boys oh that he
got turgid about does boxing glove
errors on full display
[Music]
you